what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so what I want
to do here is I want to cover I haven't
done that intro for a while so so what I
want to do here is I want to cover
Superman red Sun but the cool thing
about this is that as it was originally
released it was done in three volumes it
was like red sun rising and then Red Sun
ascendant and then I think Dawn of the
Red Sun or something like that I can't
remember but nonetheless we're actually
going to cover the three volumes and
we're going to do it in three separate
videos so super Red Son was written by
Mark Miller and it was designed to turn
the concept of Superman on his head and
it was really cool because it had never
really been done in this way before
there have been stories where Superman
was Russian but it was never really
expressed or never really thought out to
his fullest extent in a huge three-part
series instead it was usually like an
old school story where it was like you
know a standard 20page comic when the
DAT was saved at the end and that kind
of thing or it just turned out the
Superman was captured by the Russians
and tricked into being a Russian or
something along those lines but it was
never like this full you know what would
happen if Superman landed in Russia and
how would the whole superhero landscape
of the world look like if Superman was
Russian you know what would Russian
Batman and you know all these different
characters be like the fact remains here
that the cool thing about this what Mark
Miller does is he delves into a lot of
history now the way the story opens up
is it really deals with a lot of people
panicking and a lot of people freaking
out and in fact president Ike President
Eisenhower actually addresses the nation
directly and what he basically says is
that there's a new age Dawning there's a
new era coming about where the entire
conflict between Russia and the United
States is changing and the cold war is
going on a collision course that will
result in the destruction of one of
their two Nations and in a lot of ways
it does but to Sidetrack here for a
second for those of you guys who are not
really familiar with us history Russian
history world history the Cold War was
this war between the United States and
Russia that lasted decades but the
difference and the reason why it's
called the cold war is because the
United States and Russia never
officially went to war instead we really
just had what were considered to be
proxy conflicts now the reason why the
United States and Russia never went to
war is because both countries were
amping up their nuclear weapons program
and and that's why it was such a huge
deal back then because if the US and
Russia had gone to war it would not have
been a war of artillery we wouldn't have
invaded Russia Russia wouldn't have
invaded us it would have just been mad
mad mutually assured destruction meaning
both countries would have just launched
nuclear weapons and destroyed each other
and so that's why the Cold War was such
a huge deal but when it came to the
start of the Cold War this was rooted in
World War II of course World War II
changed the boundaries of a lot of
countries it allowed the formation of
Yugoslavia different things like that
but World War II took traditional
conflict from artilleries ter of
armament to ushering in the nuclear Age
of War and that's why Albert Einstein
once said I don't know what World War
III will be fought with but I know World
War I will be fought with sticks and
stones because the next huge conflict
that engulfs the world will be a nuclear
conflict that could potentially usher in
nuclear winter wipe out Humanity that
kind of thing but the fact remains here
that with the Cold War we got a series
of proxy conflicts so it was like the
Korean War the Vietnam War the Soviet
Afghan war the Cuban Missile Crisis
about a 131 14-day Panic it was about
the closest the United States of Russia
ever got to launching nuclear weapons
against each other but it was the USSR
putting missiles in Cuba which was a
response to the United States putting
missiles in turkey and so it was all
these different things that were going
on the formation of the CIA and all that
kind of stuff the world was changing
rapidly during the Cold War but during
the main Cold War itself it was the
Space Race the race to get satellites
and cosmonauts and astronauts into orbit
as well as the nuclear arms race to
create as many nuclear weapons as
possible so that if it came down to it
whoever had the most nukes would win and
so the idea here is that instead of
Superman red Sun saying hey here's the
nuclear arms race it's a superhuman arms
race and the reason why is because
instead of Superman Crash Landing in
Kansas when he was sent away from
Krypton he crash lands in Russia now
Crash Landing in Russia again it changes
everything because now Russia has a
super weapon in the form of what amounts
to an indestructible man the reason why
this is so important and the reason why
Mark Miller really did this is because
it shows us how important and how
powerful Superman is because when you
think about it you have Green Lantern
you have Hal Jordan you have Wonder
Woman you have Jon Jones you have a lot
of these really cool characters but back
when Superman first showed up he was the
big kid on the Block there was no
equivalent to Superman when he first
arrived and so what Mark Miller's doing
is he's hearkening back to the Golden
Age of comics the Superman first showed
up and saying he's the big guy here
everybody else is second best no one can
go against the Man of Steel the other
half of this is we really get a change
up for a lot of characters that we know
and love for example Jimmy olssen was
well established to be a member of The
Daily Planet Superman's biggest fan in a
lot of different ways and red son he's
part of the CIA he's part of the
government's intelligence organization
which actually grabs Lex Luther and
brings him in by way of Star Labs now
again this is a huge turning point but
in a lot of ways it also stays familiar
and the reason why I say this is because
the dichotomy between Superman and Lex
Luther is like a Hallmark I mean what
people think of heroes and villains
where they think of like the arch
nemesis of various superheroes Superman
is Lex Luther Batman is Joker it's these
great aspects that are Timeless I mean
the battle between Superman and Lex
Luther is timeless they'll always be
enemies they'll always be villains it's
cool to see things change up for a
little while that's why DC reapir is so
cool because we get good guy Lex Luther
from The New 52 but it's also one of the
reasons why you know I think after s or
somebody brought it up a lot of us are
hoping that like Mr oz in DC rebirth is
actually Lex Luther from the pre New 52
landscape because that would be super
cool but the fact remains here that Lex
Luther is very much obsessed with the
idea of Superman not only that he's
still extremely smart here now this is
something El to keep in mind Lex Luther
has red hair here and the reason why is
because when he first popped up in DC
Comics he was a redheaded guy and so it
was cool that it's just the small things
that Mark Miller grabs and throws into
the story hearkening back to the
original appearance of a lot of these
characters Lois Lane herself looks like
classic Lois Lane from the Golden Age of
comics you know I guess really kind of
the golden and silver age of comics it's
just the way these characters are
depicted that really kind of show us how
things looked back in the day but what
ends up happening here is Lex Luther
sits down you know of course because
he's basically been contracted by the
CIA to work on behalf of the federal
government to find a way to basically
counter Russia's Superman he says we
need our own Superman I mean if Russia
Superman is basically going around
saving the world but doing it on behalf
of Russia then he's making Russia look
good in the eyes of the world is this
continued expansion of Communism as
opposed to the United States policies of
capitalism we need our own equivalent
and so what he does is he calls the
president and says look I need a Russian
satellite to crash in a metropolis if
the Russian satellite comes crashing
down then what I'm hoping will happen is
that Superman will fly to its rescue and
he'll basically say whoever's there
he'll stop the satellite from crashing
and that's exactly what happens I mean
that's what we'd expect and that's kind
of the cool thing here is the elevation
of Superman from being a good guy to
being this dictator that takes over the
world is not overnight it's a slow build
it's a slow flame and that's why I love
Mark Miller stories because he's really
really good at starting with something
simple and turning it into something
extremely in-depth and extremely
convoluted especially when it comes to
Turning characters on their head he's
super good at that kind of thing but the
fact remains here that with Superman
with us seeing him really for the first
time in full uniform it's beautifully
done his costume as red sun is actually
pretty badass to be honest with you guys
I mean I like it I really love the way
that it looks but it's still classic
Superman in terms of how he acts he
hands a balloon to a little kid he's
saving the day saving the iconic you
know Daily Planet logo that comes
crashing down from the building but what
we also get is this first encounter
between Superman and Lois Lane now again
Lois is the first lady of comics in my
mind it'll always be that way she's the
first lady of comics the quintessential
Damsel in Distress she has no
superpowers to speak of but she's one of
the most important characters in the
history of comic books because she is
what DC used to ground Superman if it
wasn't for her he would just be an alien
guy from another planet who looks human
and has incredible Powers but Falling in
Love with a vulnerable human who could
be killed by any number of means a
bullet a car that hits her too fast
falling from a building she could die of
a stroke there's a lot of things that
could kill Lois Lane and so we have this
you know vulnerable human being that
could die any number of ways who is the
heart of this virtually indestructible
man it creates this incredible dichotomy
this beautiful dichotomy but we we don't
really get a tried andrue Superman
lowest Lane relationship here instead
Mark Miller just kind of teases with us
he's like hey guys wouldn't it be
awesome if they got together well
they're not and it's really cool the way
that it's done but again you know Lois
Lane is married to Lex Luther here but
it's also very tenuous in the sense that
Lex Luther is not a tried and true guy
now transitioning from America over to
Russia we get this perspective but we
also learn that there's trouble in
Paradise here the grass is not really
greener on the other side the people in
Russia love Superman because they save
him from various things and it's really
kind of like how people in America
perceive Superman in DC Comics but the
other half of this is that Joseph Stalin
has a son named Peter roslof now roslof
is designed to be this Superman redson
allegory to Pete Ross who was really one
of Superman's closest friends when he
was in Smallville so again we're going
to get this recuring theme we're going
to get a Russian version of Lana Lang
and so it's really cool how this works
out but roslov is extremely jealous of
Superman for a lot of different ways you
know first and foremost rosof is an
illegitimate son of Stalin and Stalin
had a lot of those Stalin had Sons Where
he'd have intercourse with women just
randomly they produce children and he
would never really take care of them he
would just kind of be like they're there
but he wouldn't really care roslov is
one of those very few examples at least
in the story anyway where Stalin
actually took one of his illegitimate
children in now roslov is head of the
kamaria basically what's equivalent to
the internal affairs or or really the
secret police he's just kind of like the
captain of the police in Soviet Russia
but the idea here is that in the eyes of
rosoff even if he is an illegitimate son
he's the biological son of Joseph Stalin
and so because of that when Superman
appeared on earth when he was basically
taken in by Joseph Stalin and Stalin
started doting over him and treating him
like his real son it created a lot of
animosity between roslof and Superman
the s that rosof absolutely hates him
now this will start to change a little
bit but then Rosso's life is going to go
to Absolute hell here in a little while
but the fact remains that we actually
end up transitioning to this great big
huge grandios party this being thrown
between Joseph Stalin and and really you
know hippo from them skir or of the
Amazon now this is something else that I
wanted to address here when it came to
the idea of Communism in Russia one of
the crazy things here is there's a lot
of debates that go on right now between
like you know communism and capitalism
people say well communism never works
look at Russia well Russia is not real
communism Russia had what was called
Vanguard communism and what I mean here
is during World War I you had Leon
trosky you had Vladimir lyen you had a
handful of guys who came in they ushered
in the Bolshevik Revolution where they
cast out Nicholas thear and his family
executed them all including Anastasia
and basically just implemented their own
brand of Communism the difference with
this is that unlike KL Marx's view of
Communism where everybody ader to the
betterment of the state itself and there
are no people who are running the show
under Leon trosky under Vladimir linen
under you know when Stalin took over and
you know Lyn and trosy were effectively
removed for the picture we had this
introduction of Vanguard communism in
the sense that you basically had like an
inner party you had a ruling party and
much like Nicholas thear they lavished
themselves with all kinds of parties and
wealth and extravagant things and
because of that it created this
continual idea of Oppression that's one
of the reasons why Animal Farm continues
to be one of the classic story because
it basically says that the Russian
people cast off one form of Oppression
for another form of Oppression so it was
you know out of The Frying Pan into the
fire but the fact remains here that what
we're getting is this really cool
circumstance where it is uh this
continued expansion of the Superman
redon Mythos in terms of how he deals
with Russia but also Wonder Woman now
Wonder Woman is a character where
historically she's always had kind of
like an onag again off again
relationship with Superman I mean in
truth depending on who you talk to a lot
of people liked the idea of Wonder Woman
and Superman getting together but in my
mind that was just too easy it was too
convenient you know it's it's too easy
to pair two extremely iconic characters
together because you know it's like
putting a square peg into a square hole
Yeah it fits but sometimes we want what
doesn't fit sometimes we want what just
you know it just kind of [__] your head
to the side and says really and that's
why the lowest Lane Superman thing just
went along so well plus lowest Lane of
Superman had been a thing for decades
and decades and decades Wonder Woman
just didn't really seem to fit in there
but the idea here is that she's very
enamored with Superman because she sees
him in a lot of ways like herself Wonder
Woman is very strong she's very powerful
she's very empowered Superman is much
the same way because of this there's a
lot of talk here that the two of them
will basically have a coupling they'll
start a family and they'll basically
kind of create this Allegiance so to
speak between the Amazon and Russia now
this is a big deal because what we're
talking about here is a huge expansion
of Russia's influence into other parts
of the world especially we consider the
fact that them mosir in a lot of ways
wanted to remain isolated the fact that
they're reaching out here and saying hey
let's join the Russians shows that as an
isolated country whose Allegiance could
go either way to the United States or to
Russia they're basically saying Russia's
winning the race here now this is where
we start to get into the idea that there
are consequences for everything
especially when it comes to the
introduction of Batman we won't see him
until the next video but the idea here
is that roslov had basically been
missing from the party and Superman went
to go find him and when he found him
roslov was just taking his irritation
taking his anger out you know with
target practice but the two of them have
this sort of discussion where rosof says
look I hate you you took my father's
attention away from me and it was
brought to you and because of that I
will never be the son that he wants you
are the ICONic son that he wants and of
course he says you know you're not even
really human I don't understand why
you're here and it's really just kind of
an airing of grievances the fact that he
says that he hates him now what Ros slav
also does as he talks to Superman about
the assassination of a couple parents
and what he says is that these parents
are basically printing anti-s Superman
leaflets now of course because Superman
is a representative of the communist
state the secret police are harsh and
they bring down wrath on anybody who is
against Superman it's the equivalent of
priny leaflets and saying down with
Stalin Stalin needs to die now this is
true this is actually how St and ran
communist Russia back then if you went
out and you ranted against the boss they
would have you killed you'd disappear
into a black bag somewhere and no one
would ever see or hear from you again
either you'd be executed you'd be thrown
into a Work Camp I mean there'd be a lot
of things that would happen but the fact
remains they would basically remove you
from the equation and so it was very
much a Culture of Fear much like Nazi
Germany because if people sat down and
they had feelings that were against the
government they didn't know if the
person they were talking to was a spy or
if they were actually a person that
shared the same kind of feelings they
did did and so that's one of the reasons
why a lot of people just kind of kept
their opinions to themselves they were
constantly terrified you know because
imagine if you were walking around and
you were saying man I really do not like
the president of the United States now
imagine if the person you were talking
to you didn't know if they were going to
arrest you for saying that or if they
were going to be like yeah man I feel
the same way that kind of fear is what
gripped communist Russia Nazi Germany
that's why those totalitarian
governments are so feared but the idea
here is that there's consequences for
everything in the sense that when rosoff
killed these parents it was the
equivalent of Joe Chill killing the
parents of Bruce Wayne and the normal DC
timeline and so because of this because
of the fact that roslov allowed this
young boy to run away and even went as
far as to shoot him in the back even
though the fact that he lived it sets
the stage for this boy growing up to
become Batman to become this one person
that speaks out and tries to bring down
Superman's regime but what Roff also
says is that in his heinousness in his
anger and his wrath he's done so many
terrible things and he looks at Superman
and says in the eyes of the world or in
the eyes of the Russian people you're
going to usher in a new age you're going
to save the world but what he says is
people like you don't do anything but
bring pain among others and this is a
very good point because Ros slav is
actually basically saying with absolute
power comes absolute corruption a time
will come when you're going to be forced
with a choice you're going to come to a
fork in the road you're going to be at a
precipice and you're going to have to
make the choice between implementing
something that basically forces
totalitarianism continues Joseph
Stalin's views or you're going to
deviate and you're going to go the other
way and you're going to create a culture
of freedom but regardless of Which
choice you make one leads absolute
destruction of virtually everything of
all free will free ideas the other one
will lead to the destruction of humanity
because people will use that freedom to
inevitably destroy themselves and so he
says look you're setting the world on a
collision course you're going to bring
things crashing down around us now from
here we basically pick up with Joseph
Stalin dying of cyanide poisoning now
the fact that Joseph Stalin is dying
makes things even more terrifying for
the United States and the reason for
this is because whether people are
overtly saying it or they're Whispering
it in Corners most everybody has their
eyes on Superman to be the successor
people are saying look we have this guy
that literally saves people I mean it's
not some leadership role it's not he's
saving people by being a moral leader
he's literally saving people by keeping
buildings from exploding by pulling
people out of Harm's Way being almost
anywhere in the blink of an eye he is a
physical savior at the same time Lex
Luther had been continuing to work on
basically cloning Superman and so what
we get is essentially this Bizarro kind
of Superman and here's a funny thing
it's interesting when you think about
Bizarro Superman coming from the US
because Superman is a homegrown
character he was created in Cleveland
Ohio and so he is very much an
americanmade superhero he's
representative of humanity which is why
he's so popular is because yes he was
made in America but he's a reflection of
what all people can aspire to be so he's
as much a reflection of the French and
Russian and Canadian and German people
as he is the United States because with
the exception of borders most people
think the same way and view the same
things value the same kind of things but
the idea here is that when we think of
somebody creating a Bizarro version of
Superman we don't think of the United
States doing it we think of somebody
else doing it and so it's kind of kind
of cool that we get this Bizarro version
of Superman that comes from us the other
cool thing though is that this is as
close as we get to the traditional
Superman that we all know and love in
the sense that Superman 2 as is referred
to by leex Luther is basically sent over
to encounter Superman and to basically
take him out now the two of them start
fighting one another the two of them
start uh engaging in battle with one
another and the battle is so extreme
that the British actually panic and fire
off a nuke and so because of this it's
really this situation where with them
fighting throughout Britain with the
idea that Britain's kind of panicking
the Superman actually sits down and
actually makes a decision to sacrifice
its life and save everyone now this is
something that we would expect the real
Superman to do the real Superman would
sacrifice his life if it meant saving as
many people as possible that's why he
died in the fight against Doomsday the
Russian Superman was not nearly as quick
to make that decision now it doesn't
mean that the Russian Superman doesn't
care about people it doesn't mean the
Russian Superman cares less about people
all this is really Mark Miller doing is
sitting down and saying here is what the
real Superman would do here's the
difference between the traditional
Superman in terms of his moral compass's
Viewpoint what it is that he wants to do
and the Red Sun Superman and so because
of this with the death of this Superman
2 this destruction of it as well as the
death of Joseph Stalin again everybody's
looking at Red Sun Superman to be the
one to take over the country to be the
one to lead everything and of course he
even tells rosoft I don't want to be
that guy I do not want to be the leader
of Russia I do not want to be thrust in
this position I don't want to have
anything to do with that now from here
we switch back to Lois Lane and again
this is Mark Miller hitting home with
the idea that Superman Lois Lane should
be together but they're not now it's not
super overt it is kind of to a degree
but not in our face being plastered
everywhere it's really just lowest Lane
sitting down and saying that she's had
the same dream every night for almost
her entire life that Superman always
saves her that she's falling and
Superman flies in and he saves the day
now of course again this is Martin
Miller kind of teasing us saying hey
look this is how things are supposed to
be this is the direction things are
supposed to go in but they're not it's
not a perfect world here it's not the
Superman that we're used to what we also
get here is Lex Luther calling up his
wife Lois Lane and saying hey look I'm
getting a separation I'm more or less
putting our marriage on Hiatus it's not
an an official divorce you know just
because of the fact that even back then
divorces were looked at with very skewed
eyes especially with Lex Luther being
such a public figure it would look
extremely bad if he got divorced and
back then if a woman was divorced by her
husband Society at the time as backwards
as it may have been would look at her
and say clearly she's failed as a wife
so again that's how people used to view
things back then but of course Mark
Miller's goal here is returning Lex
Luther to the traditional standard that
we expect in the sense that he has an
absolute hatred for redson Superman and
he looks at him as the guy that
basically ruined his life now this is
just him basically saying hey look I
want to take Superman out because one he
destroyed my creation and two because
the creation that I made beat me in
chess but it's really just him saying
Superman's got to go we got to find a
way to get rid of him now the way this
first volume actually wraps up is with
Superman effectively undertaking the
mantle of becoming Russia's leader and
beginning the process of taking over the
world by an unlikely source as he's
going through and as he is flying around
and looking for things to save people
from he actually comes across the
Russian version of Lana Lang now of
course this was his child childhood
sweetheart and even in DC Comics and the
traditional Superman origin stories
whether it's Jeff John Superman whether
it is Alan Moors whatever happened to
the man at tomorrow the touched on his
origin regardless of how it is you know
Superman Birthright all these origin
stories remind us that Lena Lang played
a very important role and Superman
becoming the hero that we all know and
love but they also had this kind of
romance for a time and Superman talking
to her comes to the realization that
she's basically starving her family
they're not able to eat as well as they
should because again all the money that
existed in Russia was being just kind of
thrown away and spent on lavish Parties
by the ruling party and so because of
that Superman sits down and says okay
fine that we're going to rescue them
we're going to save the day we're going
to tell people you don't have to be
scared you don't have to be hungry we're
going to have an unrivaled era of Peace
the problem with this is that the peace
they experience effectively comes at the
wrong end of a gun at the business end
of a rifle and so yeah Superman's going
to bring peace to Russia he's going to
bring peace to the world but it's going
to cost everybody virtually everything
that they want it's going to cost them
everything that matters it's going to
cost their free will but if you guys are
new here to Comics explain and you guys
want to see the second volume next week
make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button to become part of the robore if
you guys enjoyed this make sure you drop
a like and uh leave a comment down below
let me know what you guys think because
I'm curious what version of Superman do
you think is better do you think it's
better to have a Superman that actually
takes over the world like in terms of
Storytelling I mean do you think a story
where Superman takes over the world is
better than a story where Superman saves
the world cuz I'm kind of curious I
personally like dark versus a Superman I
Like It where Superman's just like an
evil guy because we're so used to him
being a good guy but I like evil
Superman I think it kind of works well
but in any event we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end and uh
yeah I will catch you all later
peace but this is not another tragic
love
so in the
[Music]
end the letter in my wallet I'll keep it